headed to round two to kind of kick off
this Reebok collab super excited about
it nice little Charity element people
gonna do a little raffle we're gonna
match the donations put some Carmen to
the world honestly you know just a fun
little event to just say what's up to
some enthusiasts around the meet friends
world or my content hang with my crew I
call it operating Destiny how are you
been yo man I've been watching for a
while so I appreciate that yeah thank
you what's your name
yeah I'm a little nervous don't be
nervous
no I guess my only thing is uh so I'm uh
who's the doctor yoga there yes like
body Rehabilitation yes
I love the way you're talking keep going
so people so women yes and I guess men
somewhat 40 to 70. yes
but Instagram too
are you gonna make videos are you gonna
do pictures what are you gonna do both
yeah I mean I would do YouTube shorts
Tick Tock Instagram Facebook for damn
sure and I would start a Facebook group
that's what I was thinking do it don't
think it [ __ ] do it start it
everyone's sick
everyone's in college
think your way into the brave yeah do
your way to the Grave right like
everyone everyone's thinking thinking
about the algo
dude why do I have answers because I do
then I tell you
yeah got you yeah
such a pleasure I've been I discovered
you when I was in high school in 2013
and I've been watching you since then
honestly you've changed my life and I
wouldn't be where I am without you
um yeah so thank you so much what's your
name uh delay good question please for
you
um so I'm a I'm a founder of YC's Boise
founder
um and you know for the past two years
been working on stuff trying to go from
zero to one trying to find product
Market fit and it's been hard and taught
we haven't
that's cool right where we realized like
who we built it for like it wasn't good
for them but there's like somebody else
somebody else finds value in it and
we're turning that corner so the thing
is the last two years have been so hard
that I have to again restart the content
again right it's a different market
right I got it right
I just I know I'm not sure no I don't
have the energy
I get it so yeah so you get a job but
but I know I can make it work but what
what do you want oh of course I know I
can do a lot of things but of course I
want it but so it might just take a
little longer because you need a little
more work-life balance and you can't put
those hours in so it might just take you
a little longer to make it work than it
would have if you figured it out two
years ago but there's nothing wrong with
that
yeah it's just that time is short you
know no it's not
oh yeah like our Runway is short we're
short I see yeah so if it's like I have
to go now you know I mean like at the
pace that I that I was at two years ago
and you don't have the stomach for it as
much it's not that I don't have a
stomach for it it's just like I'm more
drained I'm more burnt well that's
called the stomach right
I get it I get it but here's the good
news all the outcomes are okay yeah like
if you didn't go hard enough because you
didn't have the stomach for it because
you're drained yeah and you ran out of
money because the runway was short yeah
it's okay that you failed and went and
got a job right
yeah no I'm okay with that I could say
yeah I mean but but I'm trying to break
it down for you because it's really
important yeah
yeah it's okay right okay I I understand
you'd like it not to yeah but it's okay
right yeah it's also okay to say
actually you know what I'm gonna [ __ ]
take this meditation 48 hour thing get
completely refreshed and go hard for you
it's all okay right that's the part that
I really want people to understand it's
just okay
right like because if you're talking
through with me if we have two hours
yeah what
I would say look what I'm gonna say I'm
gonna say you should go hard
you might not go hard and in seven years
you may regret that you didn't go hard
right
but you're feeling the micro burnout or
not as much Henry's two years ago right
now so that's real right it is yeah it
just [ __ ] is yeah I mean I I know
your content inside and out and to me so
here's my question because I feel like
you know a lot of your content is very
focused on post product Market fit it's
more of a distribution pushing it out
what do you tell people from the zero to
one where it's like look there's there
might not be demand for the thing you're
doing I would argue that a lot of my
content touches on that it's in the
context of
maybe you're not supposed to be an
entrepreneur like product Market fit has
to do with Talent of the founder right
yeah but the thing is like so so I mean
like the way raise more Capital no the
way I've always thought about is like
okay right now in the building product
phase talking to customers trying to
build yeah I got it right and not in the
built content phase is that the right
away thing fine well of course but if
you build but to me it's both because if
you've been building content yeah maybe
you'd have VCS knocking on your door
right looking to give you money right
now what you're going to be worrying
about right running out of Runway right
so to me content is always a good idea
right even if you're like just there's
nothing content might have led to you to
getting a new employee right or a
different partner right or somebody
might have said something to you from a
video that made the product Market
didn't happen faster right content is
oxygen don't let the money burn a hole
in your pocket you know the way people
say money Burns a holy pocket and they
really mean you just want to buy some
fresh gear
actually a lot of times it's in this
scenario where you're like what do I
invest in I want to do it proper Don't
Force It yes but keep looking for [ __ ]
that excites you to get into and do you
like selling things yeah then then find
things to sell if you if someone's lucky
enough to like selling things then they
just keep having to find things that
they like to sell sneakers wasn't a
thing that people sold when I was a kid
now it's [ __ ] real sports cards nfts
clothes it could be something left field
but find something you want to sell I
also did couches too like you said yeah
it's real holes and everything people
don't realize the free couches is real
proud of you 9 000 miles to be in New
York where I started a company in
Mauritius do you know the island it's an
island in the Indian Ocean one and a
half hour a flight from Madagascar one
of the first book was that I wrote this
is how I discovered you in 2015. it's
amazing so yeah and I prepared three
questions you need to decide which one
you're going to attend because you don't
have a lot of time go ahead online
marketing platforms education digital
marketing budget allocation or business
at scale business and scale business
okay so what do you think the three most
common mistakes of businesses who are
trying to scale from one million dollar
or five million to 10 million dollars
lack of trust of their employees
all right
um
believing that they want to take too
much money out of the business
to go from one to ten
you have to when you do three million
you still have to act like you're doing
300 000 personally you can't be buying
all this [ __ ] so taking too much money
out
not trusting their employees AKA
micromanaging you can't get to 10
million if they're doing all the same
[ __ ] you gotta let people make mistakes
and number three really is only thinking
about getting more business and not
worrying about retention yeah the best
customer the next best customer you're
gonna get is the one that you kept that
you already had that makes sense and by
the way this is going to be a tick tock
and it's going to be my 118 18.
you're welcome good to see you nice to
meet you bro I'm a previous student yes
in college I'm not much of a business
entrepreneur but I have a personal
question yeah
that all comes from the same place of
insecurity of like not believing in
yourself and or over worrying about what
they think about you which one do you
think it is
life continues I guess you're gonna find
someone else you love yeah but you can't
I don't think of that like right now
because I'm 18. you know there's no 18
there's no 18 excuse here it's not about
being 18. there's people at 18 that
[ __ ] change the world there's people
at 18 that take care of their entire
family because their parents died 18
isn't the problem it's your natural DNA
in perspective
like you're letting fear dictate your
actions everyone's scared I'll flip it
on you the fact that you're 18 and
mature enough to understand that fear
and scared is real that's a strike that
means you're halfway home the other
halfway is practicing losing you got to
start doing [ __ ] that's scary and have
it not work out so you can [ __ ] taste
it
got it you understand absolutely go do
something scary go do something scary
put yourself out there you want a job in
web 3 yeah you should apply to 500 jobs
in web 3. literally go to Google Search
web free jobs nft jobs blockchain jobs
enter and literally apply to 500 jobs
okay and then
they're all technical or like they're
all like no it runs the gamut like every
nft project needs PR needs creative
needs project management needs mods what
people struggle with is they overthink
[ __ ] and they don't do you could all
these days and weeks that you've been
thinking you could have applied to seven
jobs
now maybe you're protecting yourself and
you don't want to get rejected and you
don't want your feelings hurt or maybe
you're lazy but really you're lazy
because of that or maybe who knows what
do you think
um it's a bit of um maybe just a bit of
being scared you know yeah them saying
no sometimes yeah I've tried applying
you know how many times
um maybe like five five good so 495 more
then you can come back I started my own
business at 23. wow
that's good for you
because he comes to meet paradise and I
just know my way
I tried you tell them right yes but he
doesn't doesn't want to listen yeah but
I don't know everything about the
business season either so of course
I've watched your videos and you're like
you're like no you know everyone doesn't
know everything that's right I think I
know everything
fair enough right so what's the problem
should I stop or just encourage should
you stop telling him your advice no you
shouldn't tell them what to do you
should tell them how you would do it and
then let him decide how he will do it
that's the park that [ __ ] Mom's up you
don't want him to fall in his ass the
best thing that can happen to him is he
falls on his ass even if he goes into
debt course
that's hard of course it's hard it's not
your principle
but you but if you let him go in debt
first of all if you're telling him
everything that he's doing wrong and he
starts going into debt slowly he's gonna
know that you are right he's not gonna
go as deep into debt as you think he
can't be [ __ ] on Mom and that's
wrong but also asking for like going
into like he's got him he's got to live
you definitely did if you left the 12
and did your thing you made a [ __ ]
ton of mistakes of course I
know what you mean which is why I'm
telling you it's the flip of what you
think every second you're over
protecting him is more of him becoming a
losing fighter
debt is good for him
he has no other option what are you
going to overcodile him to the grave no
so he's going to end up being insecure
because he's going to think his mom
never believed in him and more
importantly he's gonna end up being
insecure because he is seeing through
your actions that you're over cuddling
him thus meaning you don't think he can
do it
losing than having a mom that doesn't
think he can do it
like just talking to your mom having
that context like
what are you scared of failing
people think almost of course it's also
like lonely of course it's extremely
lonely it's real lonely out here for
entrepreneurs
a couple things one you'll always lose
in life if you overvalue them if it's a
wrap you're gonna have to start
practicing getting like you have to
fight for that you have to like you have
to fight you have to like really
meditation reading positive things in
your ears whatever the [ __ ] it is the
exercise I don't know what it is you
gotta practice having them judge you
then it starts getting Less Lonely Too
once you get over that first hump
what ends up happening is when you're
not scared you become more vulnerable
and open and more [ __ ] starts coming to
you when you're scared of blocking
people you're blocking energy
you're like well yeah you don't want to
talk to anybody you're scared if they're
gonna be like you're a dork you can't
talk about crypto of course you're like
I got a t-shirt exactly but I respect
that more you're doing it thank you
you're doing
shelves in a store for [ __ ] 20 years
of my life before I did anything
wow is right I've been following you for
years now and um and like I kind of took
your advice around just like just go off
and dude stop watching me I finally feel
like I've got this flow and and I I know
how to like navigate this reality and it
feels good and yeah it's great and my
question for you is um what are the
three questions
that you're most excited about answering
in life in business right now
my framework doesn't work that way the
thing I'm most interested in answering
is the question that the person wants me
to answer how do you connect with that
it comes natural to me but it's [ __ ]
real it's like I don't have selfish
interests around questions I have
selfless interests around questions so
in your mind you're my type of person
here and I ask you a question and you're
going through like what it's in how can
I make this good for him how can I
answer this in a way that might be
uniquely different than maybe something
he's heard watching me on a screen that
might connect in a way that makes him do
something that he wants for himself or
his family
thank you
Center a block from here yes and I do
everything literally everything of
course
I get it I mean I didn't fully go there
when I first started but I was almost
there is it bothering you right now
can you afford to hire an entry-level
employee to do the ship that you most
hate doing
no but I could
can you charge more for your service
yeah I know you can so that's the answer
by you having the courage to walk one
block over and changing the price from
80 an hour to 120 you can then hire that
person to do the things that you don't
want to do the smaller things which
immediately makes it more sustainable
it's the fear of raising the price that
kills solo entrepreneurs and her
competitors are not real competitors
even you can see somebody cutting your
hair and you cut hair somebody doing
yoga and you do yoga somebody being a
barber and you do Barber but it's not a
competitor because you're uniquely you
and whoever likes doing it with you
likes doing it with you that's true
there is no [ __ ] competitor we have
the juice the competitor is your [ __ ]
head telling you [ __ ] that's not true
like I can't who am I to raise it 20
bucks that person that I think is doing
a good job is ten dollars less
that's who's [ __ ] you up that's your
competitor so people always think
they're like hard on themselves because
other people say to them yes but I don't
really get that like most people you're
hard on your own self and I really don't
get hate or anything for the music I
make and stuff it's almost like maybe I
feel like they're just not truthful but
for someone they're trying to be nice
yeah of course that's but but that's
other people's voices what most people
understand is they're boys talking to
themselves was a voice they took from
others along the way and made it theirs
the reason I believe in everything is
because my mom's voice was the only
voice I listened to and she told me all
along the way that I could so I just am
that voice yeah you need to realize
that's true that it's fake that you
don't believe in yourself that the voice
that's saying to you you're not as good
as they're saying that's a lie it's a
lie your head your voice does things you
can do it the voice you're listening to
was the one that was implanted from zero
to seven or at four or two a night you
know maybe from your parents maybe from
some other direction but it's not Joshua
thank you you're welcome
[Music]